رد الفعل الروسي جاء على لسان الخارجيه
الروسيه التي اكدت ان الهجوم على جسر
القرم هو هجوم ارهابي نفذه نظام كيف قلت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا ان
المهاجمين سيحاسبون كما طلبت المجتمع
الدولي بالالتزام بتقييد تقديم تقييم
ملائم للهجوم واتهمت زخروفه الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا بتشجيع ما سمتها البنيه
الحكوميه الارهابيه الاوكرانيه على حد
قولها واكدت زخروفا ان مثل هذه القرارات
يتخذها الجيش والمسؤولون الاوكرانيون
بمشاركه مباشره من المخابرات والسياسيين
الامريكيين والبريطاني
معنى من موسكو السيد
في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه السيد
سولينكوف مرحبا بك الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين وضع شخصيا
خطا او ما سماه خطا احمرا هو مهاجمه جسر
القرم
وكذلك هناك قطع بحريه روسيه تحرس هذا
الجسر وانظمه للدفاع الجوي ورغم ذلك تعرض
الجسر لمرات بعد مرات للهجوم واخرها هذا
الذي نحن بصدد الحديث عنه الى اي مدن يمثل
ذلك احراجا سياسيا وكذلك عسكريا بالنسبه
لروسيا
روسيا
تقوم
بتعتمد على سياسه انسانيه في حربها ضد
اوكرانيا نحن لا نهاجم الجسور التي تجمع
بين الطرف الايسر والايمان من الانهر ونحن
نحافظ على طرق الامدادات الغذائيه ولا
نحارب ولا نهاجم المطارات المدنيه وهذا هو
الاسلوب الروسي اما
اوكرانيا تسمح لنفسها ان تهاجم هذا الجسر
وهي تعلم انها تهاجم المواطنين الروس
الذين ليس لهم اي اثر في هذه المعركه
انقطعت الصوره كيف
تقيم اذا ما دمت تتحدث عن مقاربه انسانيه
لعمل القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا كيف تقيم
اذا تصريحات نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي
لمترميديف التي قال فيها انه يجب استهداف
منازل
الزعماء والقاده والمسؤولين الاوكرانيين
وكذلك منازل الاقاربهم هذه التصريحات
وحدها مخالفه اصلا للقانون الدولي
انظروا الحديث هنا ليس عن المسؤولين وما
يعلنوه ان المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين الذين يديرون المعارك في
اوكرانيا والذين يديروا هذه الهجمات
الارهابيه على الاهداف المدنيه الروسيه هم
مستهدفين بالطبع من قبل الطرف الروسي اذا
كانوا يهاجمون المدنيين الروسيين ولكن
الحديث ليس عن هذا البن الحديث هنا عن
البنيه التحتيه ان روسيا لا تدمر البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه اوكرانيا هي من تقوم
بهذا
الهجمات
الاوكرانيه يتم صدرها بنسبه 99 بالمئه
يعني عذرا على المقاطعه
ماذا سيكون موقف روسيا اذا تكرر هذا
الهجوم في نهايه المطاف في بعض التحليلات
تذهب الى ان موقف روسيا ضعيف روسيا تضم
بالمخالفه للقانون الدولي ولم تعترف بذلك
الامم المتحده وخلفت حتى الاتفاقات التي
ابرمتها روسيا مع اوكرانيا في السابق
القرم اصبح منطقه روسيه بعد
الاستفتاءات وهذا ما يعتمد قانونيا في
روسيا ونحن نعتبرها القرن منطقه قانونيه
روسيه تابعه للسياده الروسيه وهذا هو
الموقف الروسي الذي لن يتغير
ولذلك روسيا سوف تحتفظ
بحق القيام باعمال مختلفه ضد اوكرانيا وقد
نهاجم الجسور
الاوكرانيه والبنيه التحتيه مثلا في
نيكالايف كل هذا كان اهدافا شرعيه لروسيا
علما ان روسيا تتعامل بانسانيه ولكن هذا
التعامل يستمر في لحظه من اللحظات السيده
متريكوف الخبير في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه
كان معنا من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك